bu
Merhabalar Hoş geldiniz Ben de bu güzel
okula Hoş geldin sizlerle birlikte
olmaktan da çok keyifliyim
bir Konu başlığı altında stres ve kaygı
ne kadar az duyduğunuz eminim Yani bu
stresle başa çıkmak kaygıyla başa çıkmak
Devler biraz farklı açıdan ele almak
istiyorum Burada hepimiz stresle veya
işte kalbinde hayatımızın bir yerinde
tanışıyoruz bildiğiniz gibi ve özellikle
sınavlarla Ben de bir sınava hazırlanan
öğrenci annesi olarak bizzat işin
içindeyim ve anlıyorum
Sana sınav sitesi veya herhangi bir
hayata dair stres ve kaygıya karşı
hepimiz bireysel olarak farklı tutumlar
geliştiriyoruz ki bu olması gereken bir
şey Ama biz hep anlatıldığına göre
stresin sanki ortada bir stres var Ve
hepimiz onunla karşılaştığımızda buna
ait olumsuz duygular yaşa bu hız gibi
düşünüyoruz Oysa stres tamamen bireysel
bir bakış açısıdır stres ya da kaygı
durumunda nasıl davranacağını kişiyi
tutumuyla belirlenir Ben bunu bir Hayat
Döngüsü üzerinde göstermek istiyorum
Müsadenizle onun içinde bir yazı tahtası
rica etmişti şöyle bir
bu şöyle bir
çok yaşa döndüğümüz var Daha doğrusu düz
bir çizgi
biliyorsunuz geriye doğru öğreniyoruz
yani yaşam dediğimiz şey hayat dediğiniz
şey ileriye doğru gider süreç bu sürecin
her hangi bir yerinde değil şuralarda
buralarda stresler de karşılaşabiliyoruz
her Siz faktörleri ya da travmalarla
karşılaşıyoruz Şimdi iki ayrı tutun
belirliyoruz Biz aslında farklı
tutumların öne çıkan özellikle iki ayrı
yönü var değil ki hayatımıza herhangi
biri girdi kim biliyorsunuz Birbirinizin
hayatında sürekli dokunuyoruz birileri
girdi hayatınızda beş yıl kaldı çıktı şu
birisi girdi üç yıl kaldı çıktı bakın
şuralar bizim noktalarımız işte
annelerimiz babalarımız var ömürleri
yettikçe bizimle beraber ama onlarda bir
yerde çıkıyorlar
buradan şimdi bu hayatımızdan çıkan ya
da ve bu hayatımızdan çıkan hayatımıza
giren insanlar olarak değil de olaylar
olarak düşürelim bunu travmalar
yaşıyoruz buralarda biliyorsunuz
birbirimize küsünce ayrılınca ilişkiler
bitince bu hepimiz için bir tutam etkisi
yaratıyor yani tamam mı dediğimiz şey
Sadece gidip başınızı bir yere çarpma
nız ya da bir kaza geçirmeniz anlamına
gelmiyor biyolojik olarak fiziksel
olarak psikolojik olarak sizi Sarsam her
şey beyin tarafından tram olarak
algılanıyor ve ilginç bir duruma geçiyor
vücut birazdan anlatacağım şimdi
şuralarda hayatımızı etkileyen her
olumsuz olay ya da hayatımıza kitap
kişiler olduğunu varsayarsak ve biz şu
kendi yolumuzu yürümek üzerine şu
hayatımızı etkileyen olayın ya da
kişinin peşinden yönümüzü değiştirirse
Yani kendi döndüğümüz böyle ama biz
böyle giderse İşte şu makas ne kadar
açılırsa bir araya o kadar duygu durum
bozukluğu Davranış bozukluğu kaygı ve
stres geliyor şimdi biz buralarda bir
yerde olayı fark ettik Ne yapıyorum ben
Benim umrumda değil yapmak istediğim
şeyler bunlar değil ya da peşine gitmek
istediğim olay kişi bu değil bip fark
ettiğimizde 7 dönmeye çalıştığımızda şu
kadarlık alandaki yaşam enerjimizi
kaybetmiş oluyoruz ve bu süreçte
kazanacağımız Şuradaki travma ile ilgili
olarak kazanacağımız mücadele becerimizi
de kazanamamış oluyoruz işte travmaların
streslerin ya da bir şeylerin arkasından
kendi Hayat Döngüsü bırakıp akıp gitmeli
bize yarattığın büyük etki Bu mücadele
becerimizi kaybetmek Hani çocuklarımızın
hayatını kolaylaştırmaya çalışıyoruz ya
biz Ama herhangi bir şeyle
karşılaşmasında üzülmesinler düşmesinler
yaralanması lar strese girmesinler
diyoruz ya aslında onu şey yapmıyoruz
onları zamanında buralarda bunlarla
yüzleşerek
kazanabilecekleri becerileri bir
ertelemiş oluyoruz şuralara kadar iki o
becerileri engellemiş oluyoruz bu
bebeklikten başlayan süreçtir basamağa
çıkmaya çalışan çocuğu tutup
kaldırırsanız Ona iyilik yapmış
olmuyorsunuz onun kaslarıyla nöronları
yla psikolojik olarak bir şeyi
başarabilme becerisini elinden almış
oluyorsunuz Peki stres ile ilgili olarak
ya da kaygı ile ilgili olarak çok sık
duyduğumuz bir şey var
var ama işte Nasıl yapacağımızı
bilmiyoruz yani burada
travmalarda stres olayla
karşılaştığınızda nasıl başa
çıkacağımızı bilmiyoruz doğru bunu
eğitim yok çünkü karşılaştığınızda
öğrenirsiniz Bunu karşılaştığınızda
kişisel tutumlarını belirlersiniz işte
Bununla ilgili olarak mesela diyelim ki
ben 18 yaşında bir kızım var ve 19
yaşında bir kız çocuğu salgı olmayı
Bilmiyorum ki onunla yaşayarak
öğreniyorum Aslında çocuklar hayatımıza
giren insanlar bizi eğitiyorlar böyle
olan biz oradan kendinize ait gereken
Eğitimi ve dersi alıyor muyuz
yaşadığımız travmalar da böyle bakmak
lazım ben burada ne öğrenmeliyim bir
Bilge'ye sormuşlar doğru kararlar nasıl
alınır
bu doğru kararlarla alınır daha hızlı
tecrübe nasıl kazanılır doğru kararlarla
alınır doğru kararlar nasıl alınır
yanlış kararlarla alınır Evet yanlış
yaptığınız bir şeyler bir sonuç elde
etmelisiniz ki onu hayatınıza uygulayın
bakın mutluluk sadece mutluluk saf
mutluluk diye bir şey yoktur ve mutluluk
bize bir şey öğretmez Hiçbirimiz
Tanrımız çok olduğu için Hiçbirimiz
sağlıklı olduğumuz için Hiçbirimiz mutlu
olduğumuz için bir yaşam deneyimi
kazanmayı zaman ne hatırlatır bize her
şeyi yaşadığımız olumsuzluklar
başarısızlıklar onlar bize deneyim
olarak dönerler Peki ben bu stresli ya
da kaygıyla başa çıkabilir miyim tabiiki
çıkabilirim Eğer çıkmaktan yapamam
edemem diyorsanız bunu da ödülü var
başarısızlığında ödülü var çünkü mağdur
oluyorsunuz Çünkü mağdur olduğunuzda
başkalarından Şefkat ilgi ve onay
alıyorsunuz bundan da bir kazanım elde
ediyorsunuz Ama öbür türlü ben Bu başıma
gelen olayla yaşadığım o en
başa çıkabilir sen o zaman sorumluluk
almam gerekiyor o zaman cesur olmam
gerekiyor o zaman kararının arkasında
durmam gerekir Bugün sınav stresi değil
karşılaştığımız birçok durumun arkasında
çocukların o sınava ay performans
kaygısı yoktur başkalarının beklentisi
ve ailelerinin onayını alamama kaygısı
vardır Bu da biz veriyoruz tabi Peki
tekrar dönüyorum başa Biz bununla başa
çıkabiliyor muyuz iki güzel örneğimiz
var stres ya da kaygı ile ilgili olarak
yaşanmış gerçek bunlardan bir tanesi
genç arkadaşlarımız hemen yaşları
yetmeyecek yıllar önce
televizyonlarda bir program vardı bir
yarışma programı vardı
tek bir soru soruyor O sorunun cevabını
biliyorsanız
bu ve nabzınızı belirli bir seviyenin
altına indiriyor sanız para ödüllü
kazanıyorsunuz bilmiyorum aranızda
hatırlayanlar vardır benim gibi yaşı 25
olanlar bilirler bunu
Dolayısıyla ne oluyor kişi soruyu
cevaplıyor ama nabzını düşürmesi
gerekiyor nabız çok yüksek atıyor veride
bir süre var İki dakika değildi o iki
dakika içinde oturduğu koltukta kolun
adaptasyon al al
ne yaptı düşmeden de götürün alın
abone ol
O her yarışmacı nazlını düşünebilir yani
sürprizini kontrol edebilir
Evet şimdi
bu
bölgenizin olduğu etmemek şöyle birşey
Bu bir başkasının sizi Minecraft sesli
yazıyor
var
ya da herhangi üzere konuşurken
tartışıyorduk ediyoruz ya o beni
sinirlendirdi o yanlış yazdı O öyle
davranmak içimden sinirlendim
yüklediğimizde Aslında kendinize bir şey
ilave ediyoruz biliyorsunuz benim
duygularını o yönetiyor
benim hayırlı etmesine izin veriyorum
O benim duyguların üzerinde ve psikoloji
üzerinde o kişi ya da olay etkilidir
oluyorsunuz iş buldum
Yok yok
düşünüyoruz kişinin düşüncelerini
yeteneklerinin yetersizliklerini
yapabilecekleri yapalım uygulayacakları
farkında olmasına bir sürüyoruz Yani
kendi üzerine düşündük yani sizin
farkındalığını geliştiriyor Şimdi bundan
kaçıp O öyle yaptı O öyle dediği için
sinirlendim o bana bunu yapma o zaman
Peki ben neredeyim hayatımız Şu döngüsü
içinde başrol oyuncusu değil ben
neredeyim bugün edebiliyorsan
Allah hayırlı uzun başımıza gelenlerin
yüzde onu gerçekten Başımıza Gelenler
yüzde doksanı başımıza gelenlere
verdiğiniz tepkilerden oluşurlar
Doğrudur
zincirleme Reaksiyon olarak
duygularımızın düşündüklerinizin
yaptıklarınızın kontrolünü hayatımıza
giren olaylara ya da kişilere
birbirimizi yoksa Aşık Veysel'in dediği
gibi değerli olan uzun ince bir yolda
gidiyorsunuz zaten bu yoldaki söz
hakkını
oy kara hakkını kendimi öldüreceğim ben
gerçekten muazzam bir videosu vardı
Gerçekten bu hayat sizin hayatınızı
yoksa takım gerekçelerle
bırakıyorsunuz bir travma sonrası stres
bozukluğu Biliriz o
[Müzik]
var
yani siz yaşadığınız herhangi bir
olursunuz o sonucunda çökmeyi ve
vazgeçmeyin tercih ediyorsunuz yok Evet
buradan dersimi alırım ve yoluma bakarım
kabuklarına Dönerim Şimdi yine tıpta da
çok ilginç bir şey var herhangi bir kişi
ya da olay bu
[Müzik]
bu ve eğer ki size zarar verirseniz çok
yalnız yapmışsa insanla iyi bir ilişki
devlet işimiz yok ise
bu tarifi vardır kaynamakta olan duyu
organı yok ederler vücut uzaklaştığında
Neden Çünkü bütünlüğü korumak için bütün
denizin yaşam gördüğümüzü diyorsunuz Ben
Şuradaki bir olaya insan ölür 80 yılı
diğer
insan ömründe ben de
Ne mutlu beğendim yapabilecekleriniz bu
mudur
ne olacak o zaman ne stres işte çok
Strese girme ve
gerçekten Ama biz olumsuz etkileri her
şey stres ayrıldım ben de izin verirsen
şimdi buraya geliyorum Bence konuşma
yapan bir buçuk saat önceden yola
çıkmayın o
[Müzik]
Bu da Bunlar verdiğinizde sitesine sahip
çıktığında
O çok bilmiyorum tellerden biriyle
otelin eski müşterilerinden birisi çok
Sizin bir vaziyette müdürün odasına
giriyor diyor ki de benim yan oranda
gürültü yakaladı uzaklaşmamız lazım Ne
oldu efendim efendim ayağa kalkıyor yan
tarafında diyor sabahtan akşama kadar o
[Müzik]
Bu
müşterimizi nasıl oluyor olayını
başladığını sağladığı için öğrenen kadar
ısınıyor Evet kendisi diyor kadın
çarpıyor çıkıyor bütün arkadaşlarına
telefon Uçucu hepsini çağırıyor ve
akşama kadar bedava mı
Evet şimdi
ses aynı ses kişi hale kişi halı harika
kadın Ortam aynı Ortak ne değişti bakış
açısı buluştu
mı
böyle bakmadık ya o bizim de verdiğim
örnek vardı benim aynı Pencereden
baktığımızda bu tarafta yeni yapılan
uçakları görüyoruz Bu tarafta
yeşillikleri görüyoruz
Ya ben
buradan daha önceden anlatıyoruz Tamam
açıp farklı bir iletim görürken birileri
yeşillik görebilir
Evet şimdi diye
o yıllar önce Ee
sen bizi merak etme Yok meşhur
biliyorsunuz şeyler yerleştirdik Sadece
kendimi geliştirdim hayatın anlamını
bulmak vesaire gibi böyle kafalılar bizi
İşte hayatın anlamını aramaya başlamış
dolayı bir soru sorsam bir türlü
istediği cevabı bulamamış O
[Müzik]
Evet şimdi diyorum kaşığı zeytinyağını
koyuyor Bu çay kaşığıyla diyor karşıdaki
tepeye gidecek siz
oradan bana geri geleceksin ama bunun
içinde iki gün var
bu ama yazmıyor be hoşça budur oyun
video gözüm ışıktan ayırmıyor gibi
aşağıya giriyorum ve çıkıyorum diye
getirdim biliyor bilgisay taşıyorum
getirdim geldi
O kim söyler misin diyorum nedir
hayatımın anlamı
Bu bilgiye sahip aşağılanmaktan bir
usulü hesaplamak Tan başımı kaldırıp
çevrendeki güzellikleri geçtiğini
yolları bir şehitleri dağları tepeleri
görmediniz hayatın anlamı oldu aslında
elindeki kaşığa odaklandığın için
kaçırmış Bizde öyle pazar yalnız para
ödeyeceğiz borç çocuklarımızın sınavı
tertemiz farkındaysanız
daha Öncelikle bir şeyler var ama acaba
geldiğinizde camdan dışarı bakarken
Beklerken geriye döndük düşündüğünüzde
keşke
Ne yiyeceksiniz Lig bineceğiz iyi yavaş
eşya Sen de çok sevimlisin o zaman
ayıramayan
hayatta istediğin şeylere başladı iki
yaşamakta veya kaygılar ağzına
bulunmakta Ve
[Müzik]
bu hayatı dediğini aldı sandım Hani
önünüzde dünya gözüyle gördük dünya
gözüyle gerçekten Hayatın keyfini
aldıysanız
sevdiyseniz istediğiniz
bırakmışsınız bu ve sizi olumsuz
etkileyen kişiler kaygılar aslında
kazandı güzel anlamlı öğretmenler
teşekkür ediyorum Efendimiz'in o